حياكم الله قال رئيس الحكومه التونسيه علي
العريض ان جماعه انصار الشريعه تنظيم غير
قانوني مارس العنف وان عددا من قياداته
وعناصره مارسوا ارهاب او خططوا له وطالب
العريض الجماعه بتوضيح موقفها من العنف
قبل فوات الاوان نتوقف مع هذا الخبر
لنناقش في
محورين ما هي عناصر الخلاف الحالي بين
الحكومه التونسيه وجماعه انصار الشريعه
السلفيه والى اين يمكن ان ينتهي هذا
الخلاف في ضوء المعطيات السياسيه الراهنه
في
تونس
في ظرف يخوض فيه الجيش التونسي مواجهات
مفتوحه في جبل الشعانبي مع من يوصفون
بانهم مسلحون ينتمون الى التيار السلفي
الجهادي تفجر الخلاف بين الحكومه التونسيه
وجماعه انصار الشريعه السلفيه على خلفيه
مؤتمر عام كانت الجماعه تنوي اقامته الاحد
الماضي في مدينه القيروان منعت الحكومه
انعقاد المؤتمر فغضب انصار الجماعه ودخلوا
في مواجهه مع الشرطه بلغت حد اراقه الدم
بينما هددت انصار الشريعه برد وصفته بانه
سيقسم ظهور اعداء الدين على حد
قولها وضعت التطورات التي اعقبت منع
الحكومه التونسيه انعقاد مؤتمر جماعه
انصار الشريعه السلفيه بمدينه القيروان
يوم الاحد الماضي وضعت الحكومه وجها لوجه
امام التحديات السياسيه الاجتماعيه التي
تواجه البلاد وما يمكن ان تسفر عنه في هذه
المرحله وجددت الاشتباكات بين الشرطه
وانصار الجماعه في القيروان والعاصمه
التونس والتي تزامنت مع قرار المنع وخلفت
قتيلا وعشرات الجرحى بالعاصمه جددت الجدل
المتعلق بجذور واسباب الصراع بين الحكومه
والنهضه تحديدا والسلفيين الماضين بنشر
اجندته السياسيه والدينيه في تحد للحكومه
مؤتمر الاحد كان سيمثل فرصه لجماعه انصار
الشريعه للكشف عن حجمها وقدراتها وتاثيرها
في تونس ولكن التطورات جعلت من انعقاده
وفق اجنده الجماعه امتحانا لسياسات
الحكومه المرتكزه على محاور الامن وسياده
القانون واحترام الحريات والمواثيق
الوطنيه
والدوليه التصعيد مستمر حيث دعت الجماعه
انصارها للاحتشاد يوم الجمعه بالقيروان
امام مقر النهضه بينما حذر رئيس الحكومه
خلال مؤتمر صحفي بان هناك ك اطرافا تمارس
العنف والارهاب ضد اجهزه الدوله بما سماه
الغلو الديني قائلا ان حكومته لن تساوي م
على ذلك وطلب من المعنيين تحديد مواقفهم
من العنف بشكل واضح ويتزامن حديثه
والمواجهات مع جماعه انصار الشريعه مع
احداث جبل الشعابي على الحدود التونسيه
الجزائريه وملاحقه المسلحين الجهاديين
المتحصنين هناك والذين اصبحوا موضع قلق
بتونس وكل المنطقه خاصه في ظل الاعتقاد
السائد بان تونس اصبحت مركزهم بعد ان كانت
ولفتره طويله مجرد معبر لهم في ظروف معينه
تحديد المواقف ايضا بل وقراءه تفاصيلها من
قبل كل الاطياف التونسيه واقع يفرض نفسه
وبالحاء على الساحه خاصه وانه من المقرر
انتهاء المجلس التاسيسي من صياغه الدستور
في يوليو واجراء الانتخابات البرلمانيه
بين ال من نوفمبر والخم
من ديسمبر
القادم موضوع حلقتنا نناقشه مع بلال
الشواشي المتحدث باسم التيار السلفي
الجهادي في تونس ومعنا من تونس ايضا محمد
سامي طريقي عضو المكتب السياسي لحزب حركه
النهضه سيد الطريقي ربما من المناسب ان
نبدا اولا
بخلاف نفسه نحدد اطرافه وموضوعاته هل
الخلاف هو بين الحكومه وانصار الشريعه
كتنظيم ام بين الحكومه والتيار السلفي
بشكل
عام لا طبعا بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم احييك
واحيي جميع المشاهدين الناس تعرف جميعا
عند تحرير الخلاف ان الخلاف بين الحكومه
وهؤلاء الجماعه هي خلافهم بينهم وبين من
ينكر على الدوله شرعيتها هؤلاء يعني
يرفضون تماما معنى الدوله هؤلاء يريدوا ان
ينشطوا خارج الدوله يريدون ان يريدون ان
يعترفوا بقوانين الدوله وهذا خطير وخطير
جدا الخلاف ليس
بين الحكومه والتيار السلفي على العكس
هناك سلفيون يقبلون بشرعيه هذه الدوله
وينشطون في اطرها وضمن قوانينها ولكن
هؤلاء للاسف تحديدا تنظيم انصار الشريعه
يعني منهجهم رافض تماما لشرعيه الدوله
رافض تماما لوجود الدوله يعتقدون ان هذه
الدوله نزلوا قوانين يعني طاغوت قوانين لا
علاقه لها بتحكيم شرعيه شرع الله
بالحاكميه لله يعني هم تحدثون عن انهم
تنظيم غير قانوني وهذا ما سمعناه من رئيس
الحكومه اذا كيف يفسر ان هذا التنظيم سمح
له باقامه مؤتمرين في السابق في الواقع
المؤتمر الثاني تحديدا
حضره ممثلون عن حزب النهضه ووصفت فيه
الحكومه بانها حكومه
جاهليه ربما كثير في تونس وفي خارج تونس
سالون لماذا الان
الحظر طبعا لانه تواترت الاحداث اصبحت
الاحداث يعني
انتقلت بتواتر سريع نحو العنف يعني انصار
الشريعه يتبرون من هذه العمليه حسب ما حسب
ما نفهم ولكن الادله على الميدان دائما
ترتبط بهؤلاء نحن نامل نامل من هؤلاء ان
يتبروا من اعمال العنف وان يعترفوا
بالدوله وان يقدموا التراخيص اللازمه من
اجل من اجل شرعنه تواجدهم وشرعن نشاطاتهم
لنسمع لنسمع من السيد بلال الشواشي يعني
ما الذي يمنع من تحقيق هذا
المطلب اولا ارد على الاستاذ سامي لما قال
ان الادله دائما تورط هؤلاء وتدل على انهم
مرتبطون بالاعمال العنيفه او الارهابيه او
سميها ما شئت بل بال هذا كلام للاستهلاك
الاعلامي لان هناك من اطراف محايده تقول
ان الادله تدل على ان هذه الاعمال
الارهابيه والعنيفه بريئه منها انصار
شريعه والتيار سلفي عموما وانما هي تدخل
وتندرج ضمن اطار مخطط اجنبي واجنده اجنبيه
تهدف الى شيطنه هذا تيار ثم عزله ثم
استئصاله
والبارحه هناك ناشط وهو علماني وليس ناشط
اسلامي يدعى رمزي بطيبي قدم اثباتات على
قناه تلفز مشهوره هنا في تونس ان عمليه
اغتيال شكري بالعيد وسيناريو ما يحدث في
جبل الشعابي لا علاقه له لا بانصار
الشريعه ولا بالتيار السالف الجهادي انما
هناك خيوط اخرى تدل على انه يندرج ضمن
مؤامره لضرب هذا التيار وشيطنته واستئصاله
ثم نقول نحن اكدنا مرارا وتكرارا سواء عبر
مشايخنا او قادتنا او المتحدثين باسم
التيار او ادبيات المطروحه ان تونس
بالنسبه لنا هي ارض للدعوه والبيان
والاصلاح العقائدي والاصلاح الاجتماعي
والاصلاح الاخلاقي ويؤكد هذا حتى تنظيم
القاعده نفسه الذي
نحك
تظ اذا سمحت سيد بلال لنفترض ان هذه
النظريه صحيحه هناك مؤامره لشطه
في المقابل التنظيم يتهم الحكومه بانها
حكومه جاهليه هذا الكلام هذه
اللغه الا ايضا تشي بان هناك معاداه هناك
نوع
من اللغه المنهج الذي يحمي يحمل في طياته
العنف
والعداء طيب وضح كلمه جاهليه في ادبيات
تعني مخالفه الكتاب والسنه فلما يصف هذا
التنظيم تنظيم انصار شريعه او غيره من
التيار السلفي الجهادي عموما الحكومه او
النظام بانه نظام جاهلي اي ببعده عن
الشريعه الاسلاميه وتنكره لتطبيق الشريعه
الاسلاميه لكن نحن لسنا ضد مفهوم الدوله
نحن مع مفهوم الدوله ومفهوم المؤسسات لكن
اي دوله وا مؤسسات نن بالنسب ندف ال
د نستغل الوقت يعني هذا الموقف يعني اذا
كان هذا هو الراي شرعا ايضا الا يترتب
عليه مواقف عمل
هذا ما يذهب اليه الجانب الحكومي
هنا المواقف العمليه قلناها مرارا وتكرارا
ان نريد اصلاح هذا النظام الجاهلي ونريد
اصلاح هذا الفساد الذي ينخر جسد الدوله
وجسد مؤسسات باصلاح التشريعات وجعلها
متبسه من الشريعه الاسلاميه واصلاح النظم
النظم بجعلها نظم اسلاميه وذلك عن طريق
الدعوه والعمل الاجتماعي والحوار والنقاش
واقناع الناس سواء كشعب او كناشطين او
كحكومة سواء في المجتمع او في السياسه او
في المؤسسات او في غيره طيب لاعود الى
محمد سامي الطريقي يعني سمعت ما قاله
السيد ب بلال الشواشي انتم من وجهه نظركم
يعني في الحكومه كيف ترون عناصر الخلاف
بالتحديد مع هذا
التنظيم اختي اولا دعيني ان ارد انا لا
اريد ان انسحب الى صراع افكار او تدافع
بين افكار نحن امام الدوله لها قوانين
ولها مؤسسات ان يقال اننا نحترم هذه
الدوله ولا ناتم باوامر هذه مخالفه صريحه
لاقل ما يمكن ان اي مواطن ان يحترم فيه
كينونه هذه الدوله لا يمكن بالامكان ان
نقبل اي تنظيم خارج الاطر القانونيه
الحوار نعم مع جميع الاطياف وجميع
الطيارات ونحن لا نريد ان نناقش افكار
انصار الشريعه او غيرهم هذا حق لهم ان
يفكروا بال طريقه التي يردون يعني ما
نحاول ان نفهمه هنا يعني هي فتره قصيره
انت تقول انها سريعه جدا والاحداث تواترت
ولكن نحن نحاول ان نفهم ما الذي استدعى ان
تشارك الحكومه في مؤتمر وخلال فتره قصيره
تضع الان المؤتمر خارج النطاق اي شيء شرعي
قانوني وعلى الارض كانت المعطيات اصلا
قائمه كان في المؤتمر نفسه كانت هناك
اتهامات للوم اولا الحكومه لم تشارك اولا
الحكومه لم تشارك باتات في اي مؤتمر من
مؤتمرات انصار الشريعه ولكن يبقى طبعا بعد
الثوره الدوله ضعفت قليلا استغل ذلك الضعف
كثير من الاطراف والطيارات ويريدون
استهداف وجود هذه الدوله اليوم لا يمكن
القبول بعض الخط الخطوره والمخاطر التي
يمكن ان تكتسح المجتمع التونسي و كينونه
هذه الدوله لا يمكن بعد اليوم قبول اي
تحدي س لهذه الدوله للدوله هيبتها نحن مع
الحوار مع جميع الاطراف ولكن ان يقع تبويب
هذا الحوار ضمن الاطر القانونيه المقبوله
ذوقا ومنطقا وقانونا اما ان لا نعترف
بكينونته الدوله وبقوانين
ونقوم ونحرص على على انشطه ايا كانت هذه
الانشطه دعويه او غيرها تكفر هذا النظام
او لا تكفره هذا لا يهمنا ولكن يجب ان
يكون ضمن التراخيص ال المعمول بها قانونا
عدم قبول ذلك يعني هذا نفي للدوله النفي
للدوله لا يمكن ان يقبل في اي من اي طرف
كان لو كان هؤلاء
يحكمون لما قبلوا على اي طرف ان يخرج عن
هنا بلال شواشي عندما نتحدث عن طرف هل
نتحدث فعلا عن صوت واحد الشعور الذي لدينا
عندما نتحدث عن تيار سلفي ان هناك عده
اصوات تمثله ما هي مكونات هذا التيار
ولماذا هذا
الاختلاف انا هنا اتحدث عن التيار السلفي
الجهادي هناك تيارات سلفيه اخرى حتى قبل
الثورات كانت تمجد الحكومات وتمجد الحكام
الظلمه وتمجد الاستبداد هذه لا تمثلنا نحن
هنا انا هنا اتحدث باسم التيار السلفي
الجهادي ومن ضمنه تنظيم انصار شريعه اقول
للاخ سامي مساله هيبه الدوله لماذا لا
تذكر هذه الكلمه الا مع التيار السلفي
الجهادي ثم شيء اخر هناك تيارات اسلاميه
اخرى تؤمن بنفس المباد ولها نفس الاهداف
وهي تطبيق الشريعه الاسلاميه واسقاط
الهيمنه الاجنبيه على بلادنا مثل جبهه
الاصلاح مثل حزب الاصاله مثل حزب التحرير
رغم انهم مرخص لهم ورغم انهم احزاب معترف
بها قانونيا ورغم ذلك تمنع مؤتمراتهم
وخيمت وملتقيات وفي المقابل نجد اطراف
علمانيه ويسريه تمارس مظاهرات وانشطه
واضرابات تضر بالبلاد وبعباده وبالاقتصاد
ولا ولا نسمع حديثا عن طلب الرخصه او شيء
من هذا القبيل بل التحدي وصل بهم الى ان
يقولون مخاطبين الحكومه نحن لا نعترف
بقوانين لماذا لا تذكر هيبه الدوله مع
هؤلاء ولا تذكر الا مع التيار السالف
الجهادي وحتى التيارات الاسلاميه التي
قبلت بطلب
الترخيص ل التخي ويحر نشاطها بعد الفاصل
في لنناقش الجزء الثاني و والمقالات
المحتمله للخلاف الحالي بين الحكومه
والسلفيين في تونس نرجو ان تبقوا
معنا اذا اهلا من جديد الى هذه الحلقه
التي نتناول فيها السجال الحالي بين
الحكومه وجماعه انصار الشريعه في تونس اذا
سيد الطريقي قبل
الفاصل سال السيد الشواشي لماذا تثار هيبه
الدوله فقط مع جماعه انصار الشريعه لماذا
لا تثار مع اطراف اخرى علمانيه وغير
علمانيه احيانا قد تلجا الى اساليب فيها
اكثر اضرارا كما يقول
بالدوله نحن قلنا منذ قليل ان الثوره لما
قامت استهدفت او استضعفتك الدوله ونحن
الان نسترجع تباعا قوه هذه الدوله وهيبتها
لبسط القانون على الجميع وهذا غير صحيح
ويعلم سيد بلال اخ بلال يعلم جيدا ان من
استهدف شرعيه المؤسسات والمجلس التاسيسي
وقفت اليه الحكومه وناضت موقفه وادانته
نتذكر جميعا بعد مقتل شهيد شكري بعيد كيف
انه السيد بجي القائد السبسي دعا الى
اسقاط شرعيه المجلس التاسيسي وكانت مسيره
كبرى من انصار حركه النهضه والكثير من
المساندين لهذه الشرعيه ورفضوا هذا الموقف
واعتبروا ذلك خروج عن الدوله واسقاط
الدوله في في في فخ كبير وقد يصل بنا الى
مخاطر كبرى ايضا يعلم السيد بلال انه
بالمثال الذي قدمه ان هناك احزاب تطالب
بتطبيق الشريعه مثل جبهه الاصلاح وغيرها
وحزب التحرير وغيره رغم ذلك هم ينشطون
قانونا ولا يمنعهم احد ولم يصدر اي بيان
من بياناتهم يدلل على ذلك بل العكس صحيح
حزب التحرير وهو حزب مرخص له يقدم نشاطاته
ومسيرات وضمن الاطر القانونيه ولا شيء
يمنعه السيد بلال يريد ان يهرب من هذا
الموقف لا يريدون ان يقدموا اي ترخيص لا
يعترفون بالدوله لا يعترفون بوزاره
الداخليه يعتبرون طاغوت لا يريدون ان
يتقدموا التراخيص مجرد اعلام قبل 72 ساعه
لتنظيم خيمتهم الدعويه وغيرها لم يتدخل
احد في مضامينها هم يرفضون ذلك هم يريدون
فقط ان يبص تعبون الامور على انفسكم سيد
شواشي هذا هذا ملخص ما يقول الطريقي يعني
الامور واضحه وسهله تستطيعون ان تتظاهر
وتقولون ما تريدونه ولكن في اطار قانوني
شرعي لماذا تصعدون الامور على
انفسكم الاستاذ سامي احيلك على تصريحات
رضا بالحاج الاخيره وهو الناطق الرسمي
باسم حزب التحرير واحيلك على مؤتمر حزب
الاصاله الذي منع رغم انه حزب مرقص له هو
منع المشايخ المدعوون من المغرب واحيلك
على تصرفات اخرى للطيارات الاخرى التي قلت
انها تحدت القانون بشكل سافر ولكن لا
يتصدى اليها احد وقفات كل يوم اربعاء
للجبهه الشعبيه مسيره 9
التي تحدت المنع في شرحح ب بورقيبه ترشح
الباجي قيد سبسي الانتخابات وقوله قانونهم
لا يلزمني هذا كله مثبت وكل المتابعين
للساحه السياسيه في تونس يعلم ان هذه
وقائع موجوده ولست هنا بصدد المغالطه يعني
المشكله هنا هناك سياسه كيل باريد اريد
اريد توضيح نقطه نقطه بسيطه بالله عليك
نقطه بسيطه بعد مقتل شكري بالعيد بعد مقتل
شكري بالعيد
الاستاذ سامي يقول هناك اطراف ارادت ان
تدخل البلاد في فوض الم يقم السلفيون
بحمايه المنشات وحمايه مؤسسات وكانوا
بمثابه صمام الامام الامان للبلاد بعد ما
كادت ان تدخل في فوضه بعد مقتل شكري
بالعيد الا يعترف بهذا كل القاسي والداني
كل من يشاهد الوضع في تونس يعترف بان
التيار السلفي وخاصه التيار سلفي الجهادي
نزل الى الشوارع في تلك في تلك الفتره وحل
المؤس الى نقط
اخرت هنا من هو من هو الذي
يده نشعر كانها اوضحت فكرتك فقط حتى نخرج
من اطار هذه النقطه اريد ان اتحدث عن
المهله التي
اعلنها رئيس الحكومه عندما قال ان هناك
مهله
امام التنظيم ليست طويله لتحديد موقفهم من
العنف ما الذي يريده منهم بالضبط يعني وما
الذي س
ما الذي يهددهم به اذا لم
يلتزموا سيد
الطريقي هذا هذا شان الحكومه هذا ليس
شاننا نحن في حركه النهضه موقفنا واضح
يعني وهذا ما افهمه من تصريحات السيد رئيس
الحكومه وما كنت بصدده هو ان يتقدم هؤلاء
بترخيص لتنظيم نشاطاتهم وان يقدموا بترخيص
لينتظم هم انفسهم ويصبحوا هيكل واضح
للعيان في في كامل هيكلته من اجل التعامل
معه وفتح ابواب حوار معه هذا غير
معناها صعب على هذا التنظيم ان يقوم به
وان يرفعوا الحرج عن انفسهم ما يقوله
للسيد بلال منذ حين هذا ايضا غير طبيعي
وغير مفهوم ماذا يعني انه يستدل بانه منع
هذا هذه الخيمه هنا او هناك من اجل عدم
التقديم هذا الترخيص هذه تبريرات غير
طبيعيه عليك ان تتقدم بترخيص من اجل ان ان
تنشط واذا تجاوزتك الاداره في احد المناشط
يمكن لك ان تطعن امام المحكمه الاداريه
وان وان وان تطلب التعويضات من الدوله وان
انت تتبع الجهات التي محتك بطريقه ان ان
ان ان انه ليس هناك يعني اي توجه بهذا
الاتجاه سيد بلال الشواشي بل على العكس
يعني التنظيم
يتحدث عن مفاجاه ستقسم ظهور اعداء الدين
كما
سماهم يعني ما الذي يمكن ان يفهم من هذا
اعلان يعني بصراحه لو سمحتي يعني من يقرا
هذا او يشعر بان هذا تهديد قد يصل الى حد
اعلان حرب اريد ان اسمع السيد شواشي
خل دعيني اجيبك دعيني اجيبك اولا انا لم
افهم هنا الاخ سامي هل هو ناطق باسم
الحكومه ام ناطق باسم حركه النهضه الذي
يسمعك لوهه الاولى يظن انك الناطق الرسمي
ولسان دفاع الحكومه ولست تتحدث باسم
النهضه يعني هناك
تناق دع المشاهد يحكم بنفسه هل كلامي غامض
ام ليس واضح ثم اريد ان اعلن بالنسبه ل
موقفنا من العنف موقفنا واضح وصريح منذ
فتره طويله ونجدد دائما نحن نعتبر تونس
ارض جهاد البيان جهاد الكلمه جهاد الع
جهاد على من على على من على اشخاص يرفعون
يقولون لا اله الا الله هذا هو
السؤ اقولك جهاد الك الدوله الحومه اعداء
الدوله هذا هو السؤال السيد شوا انا اريد
ان
اعيدك
فق وا عندما اقول جهاد الكلمه وجهاد
البيان والجهاد السلمي اظن هذا مصطلح واضح
ج الكلمه كيف يستقيم مع قسم
ظهور اعداء الدوله يعني نتحدث هنا ليس عن
جهاد كلمه قسم
الظهور والله قد يكون المقصود به انا انت
هنا تتحدثين عن بيان عن انصار الشريعه
وانا قلت كما قلت لست ناطقا باسم انصار
الشريعه قد يكون المقصود به قسم الظهور
يعني انها مفاجاه تقسيم ظهورهم سياسيا كما
يقال انتحار سياسي كلها
الفاظ تستعمل للمجاز وليس للحقيقه يعني
هنا موقفنا واضح يعني وحتى تنظيم القاعده
الذي اتهموا باننا ننتمي اليه قال نحن لا
نستهدف في تونس لا شرطه ولا جيش ولا شعب
ولا احد ت مز عند نتحدث عن
اعدا اعداء يعطي الانطباع باننا نتحدث عن
اعلان حرب هنا وهذا هو السؤال ما هو
المخرج بشكل سريع سيد طريقي سيد طريقي فقط
سؤال سريع فقط اسالك وربما السيد شواشي
يعني لنبدا معك يعني ما هو المخرج من وجهه
نظرك ما هو المخرج سي شواشي يعني هذه
الامور وصلت الى ما وصلت اليه كل طرف يقول
هذا طرف غير قانوني الاخر يقول سنقسم
ظهورهم ما هو المخرج من وجهه
نظرك سيد الشواش المخرج اولا لا تواصل نعم
اجيبك المخرج اولا ان لا تواصل الحكومه في
سياسه الكيل بمكين وان لا تواصل التمييز
ومحاوله الاستئصال ضد هذا التيار وان
تعترف به كتيار موجود ثم اذا وجدت اذا وجد
هذا الشرط سيوجد المخرج الثاني والاهم وهو
مخرج الحوار ونحن دائما ندعو الى فتح
ابواب الحوار لنا سواء على المنابر
الاعلاميه
اووات الطريق بقي فقط دقيقه واحده بشكل
سريع جدا كيف ترى
المخرج
المخرج واضح يعني هؤلاء يقدمون ترخيص
للنشاط القانوني وان لا يكيل بمكيالين
يطالبون الدوله ان تعترف بهم وهم لا
يعترفون بالدوله هذ وقوانينها هذا فعلا
منطق عجيب غريب يعني لا نعترف بهذه الدوله
لا نعترف بقوانينها لا ناتم
بها ويطالبون ان يق تعح عن حوار تعتقد
هناك فرصه للحوار في هذه
المرحله حركه النهضه لا ترفض الحمار حوار
مع اي طرف ان كان مهما كانت ايديولوجي
ومهما كانت افكاره شريطه ان لا يرفع
السلاح ان ان ينبذ العنف وان يتبرا من كل
العنف وان ياتمر باوامر القانون هذا هذه
هذه شروط حركه النهضه من اجل فتح قنوات
حوار مع اي طرف كان محمد سامي الطريقي عضو
المكتب السياسي لحزب حركه النهضه شكرا لك
وشكرا لبلال الشواشي المتحدث باسم التيار
السلفي الجهاد
في تونس وشكرا لكم مشاهدينا الكرام على
متابعه هذه الحلقه من برنامج م وراء الخبر
نلتقي باذن الله في قراءه جديده في م وراء
خبر جديد في
ملا